hey what's up guys my name is Jenna and
welcome to episode 16 of Sparky Engine
in which we make a beautiful game engine
from scratch in C++ so today we'll be
talking about last episode was
horrendous well not really it's just
that we spent so much time on legacy
OpenGL which were obviously going to get
rid of right now but anyway today we're
going to talk about getting our textures
to work with the batch render so
basically well let's just look at what
we achieved last episode we achieved
this this texture which is exactly what
we had in our image so everything is
just the best and if I were to draw a
face on it and restart this you can see
it has that beautiful face and
everything is the best so what we're
going to do now is make it actually work
with our 50,000 sprite renderer okay
which I which is our batch render us so
we need to actually basically get it to
work with that but also we want to
prepare ourselves for next episode which
will be all about arrays of textures so
obviously we have we if we have a sprite
batch of 50,000 textures
we probably let's just say that's like a
map a tile map of something 50,000 is
such a ridiculously high example usually
you wouldn't have that many unless
you're doing stuff like particle engines
and we'll talk about that later but
usually wouldn't have that many but I
imagine if you even had like 200 sprites
on the screen maybe this is like a like
part of your like a tile kind of level
map right and in your map you would have
maybe some sand tiles some River tiles
and water tiles whatever you know you'll
have all those kind of tiles and
obviously they have different textures
so how do you set the texture per sprite
that's kind of what we're going to be
covering in the next two episodes this
one and the next one so the first step
is setting this up with the actual bash
renderer so that the batch render knows
how to interpret and apply certain
textures to sprites so to do that let's
get rid of a lot of the code that we
wrote last time I'll move this shader
dot enable we had two shaders in one
last time so we probably probably going
to just get rid of most of this we'll
leave our cool lighting thing so we'll
leave
well we just had light position and that
was it right so we'll get rid of like
layer two I'm sure you all know how
groups work now when we've covered that
we'll go back to like fifty thousand
surprised maybe not that many though but
we'll get rid of this horrible legacy
code we'll have to revert our shaders as
well in a minute but just get rid of the
second layer completely let's get rid of
so we had that let's get rid of we'll
leave our texture as well let's get rid
of layer two let's get rid of our group
testing code to test 50k sprites can
just go away now oops and we were doing
that let's so I think this was doing
less than 50 less than 50k at this point
let's get rid of the second shader so he
just got shaded unable so we'll just get
rid of that completely we're just going
to basically just simplify a lot of this
code now because we don't need to UM we
don't need to be in quite a complicated
position let's just say let's just let's
just launch this and our shaders are all
wrong well good an error all right ah
it's kind of working okay let's go into
a shaders and totally revert all that
stuff so we'll uncomment this we will
uncomment that we will uncomment this
and our GL position will be back to will
restore all of our uniform defaults and
we'll get rid of this so x ml matrix say
x review matrix x model matrix x
position I think that's what it walls it
should have been that great basic dot
flag will go back to this we'll get rid
of this and we'll bring back this will
leave the uniform sample it will need
that anyway and
that should be all reverted now and it's
not really at all but close
what's wrong with this with what's with
that color oh I got rid of something I
shouldn't have
mother duck oh and also home-like
version totally on the wrong version but
I got rid of something because what's
color are no colors legit wait that was
the comment I wasn't it was it
and I yes it's just FS in collar isn't
it yeah there we go okay good we're back
that's a lot of sprites though I don't
want to render that many that's way too
complicated let's just do plus plus
right that was a good amount of price I
believe and then I think we just did I
think we just did that
and that was like a reasonable amount of
sprites to display and it was nice yet
that looks really nice I like that a lot
so anyway now that we've got this and
not to mention the performance is great
now that we've got this going on let's
go ahead and actually set up with
textures so how do we do that right well
there's a few different things that we
should set up first of all in our basic
renderable right now we're supporting a
just vertex right a color which we
change from being a back four which is
four floats 128 bits into just 32 bits
into one unsigned in color right we can
get rid of this now everyone knows how
everything right there so what we'll do
is well actually so we'll move color
down okay so in between vertex and color
I'm actually going to set up a Veck to
okay which is going to be our text cord
I'm just going to call this UV okay so
that might be a bit that might be a bit
a bit of a bad name I don't want to call
text record texture coordinate' because
that's just too too much it's just too
long so I might just say alcohol evey
and then we'll just make a unsigned int
it doesn't need to be any inter-communal
whatever wants but we'll just make an
unsigned int called
our tid which stands for texture ID okay
so we have two things and this is going
to be this is going to be the K so that
we can support a rays of textures I
might actually put that in next episode
to keep this episode purely about one in
the next episode we'll just we'll branch
into arrays but right now what we have
is a UV okay what this means is that I'm
going to either eat a grape I hope
that's not you know making my
professionalism seem less to you but
what this is going to be is of course
the the the the the texture coordinate
essentially so that we can apply the
texture correctly to the triangles okay
but there we go
so this is per vertex remember so now we
need to tell the batch render about this
change luckily what we did was we
switched to using this offset of thing
last time nor the time before last time
I don't know where we where we use this
actual color thing instead of actually
manually specifying an offset in bytes
because we did that though because we
did that now that we've put UV in
between these we don't need to change
color anymore because it knows what
color is now so all we need to do is add
one for the other thing so share the
color index we had all this stuff we
should probably add one I'll change
color index now to be like - right and
I'll add one at index one called shader
UV index okay well this was great real
quick so this shirt this this UV index
is going to be reflected in our shaders
we'll change this to be layout location
to color okay and then we'll change will
just input one to be UV or something
like that so just I'm sticking with UV
just because that's usually the
convention of that's usually the I guess
the I know the names that you would give
texture coordinates right when you're
doing them so instead of like XY or
whatever you use UV I think it's just a
nice name that we can use and everyone
knows everyone should basically
understand what it may
is just a quick ruv okay there's the
tactical one let's make sure their
vectors as well okay cool
anyway let's close a bunch of this stuff
because we really don't need it now that
we've done that in our batch render we
can copy and paste this right make sure
it's a to coordinate thing it's going to
be a shader UV index right it's going to
be is it going to be an unsigned byte
script no it's just going to be a gel
float okay
normalized we'll set to false it
technically probably would be we'll play
around with that maybe this is going to
the stride as always it's always going
to rain the same then the offset is
going to be the offset of UV okay and
that's it that should be it so make sure
you don't forget to enable it otherwise
it won't work and you'll cry probably
maybe not but my no why should i short
probably would but there we go so
everything now is pretty good
I might split mile we're getting
somewhere in taser code I might split
this up so it into mice chunks so that
we are so that we can reach our code
easier but everything looks pretty good
and then our next step is coming into
here and actually pushing that data into
the buffer okay so right now our
rendering is pretty much broken because
the things it's thinks like things that
are different offsets and this probably
just okay or maybe not maybe it will
just work but we haven't actually
specified anything to do with our actual
I should say texture coordinates so to
do that we need to basically tell
sprites where they are I'm probably tell
drown durables where they are as well so
we've got em sighs we've got in position
and these are all things we probably
won't just have a texture coordinate
kind of thing right yes and one thing I
should mention actually is what the
reason it did work is because of offset
off okay so it basically skipped UV like
isn't it didn't skip it but it it knew
that it it knew that there was a thing
at UV and it pushed that data which was
empty but because it knows what color
actually is it only pays basically read
the
- so if we add zero one two right it
didn't read anything from one which was
a UV just read and road to zero and two
and since we only use that we didn't
have a problem so that's why it worked
in case everyone was interested but
that's why offset offers the best but
anyway to make this work we basically
want to be able to be like oh what is my
texture coordinate right or my UV now
there are a few problems with this
because UV s we don't just have one of
them and we don't have like a size and a
UV we have four of them so it will
probably make more sense to store them
in an array or a vector which is
probably going to be the better option
so if I make a vector of vectors called
UV and then I retrieve it like sorry
that's probably going to be one of the
best ways to actually do something like
that now what I'm going to do is this is
our default constructor here what I'm
going to do is basically set them up as
a standard just a standard vector of our
vectors again I'll call this M UV okay
so I do want this to be written to by
default though so what I'll do is I'll
actually expand this constructor here
we're already been using this one right
now by the way so it's probably not use
doing that always I don't think we're
using it let's take a look at our sprite
real quick that's a statics Brian status
wise using it sprite
Oh sprite is using it what do you know
so we didn't so when were using the
default constructor rolling okay we'll
do it for both constructors anyway might
as well so back over here we'll go ahead
and basically just go mu V dot pushback
maths so we'll set up defaults right so
we'll have 0 0
um I don't know I usually render I
usually start in the bottom left and
render clockwise so I will just change
this to 1 and that to 0 and whatnot and
we'll set it up that way just that just
because that's how I roll
so I should probably make some kind of
private void sets UV defaults which just
that which just does that and then I'll
just call that here and here and I'll
keep this nice and tight
okay so we'll paste that here and we
should pretty much be done okay so there
we go there's our beautiful adventure
into basically getting a default v's
let's make an inline thing called get
UVs I'm actually going to Chris say UVs
like that or 9 that just looks weird
so I'll just do this vector okay make
sure you of course get the reference of
it and you're not copying it that would
be horrific for performance muv okay
there we go so that looks pretty good to
me
if we go back into batch renderer we
should be able to access those UVs and
now all we need to do is set them up so
if we go ahead and this matter which
order you do them in I'm just going to
do in the chronological order since that
makes more sense but we're going to go
ahead and say that is equal to UV zero
for the first one and then one to enter
8 essentially so so this this part of
it's pretty easy all with the Rays of
textures I'm going to eat another grower
hopefully that's okay um with the Rays
of textures the only difference is going
to be that will have to also pass in a
an actual ID for the texture that we
want to use so we have 10 textures we
might be like I want to use texture
number 5 or something that's it the UVs
will stay the same
obviously everything else looks pretty
good so while I swallow my grape so next
thing we need to talk about is shatters
we need to have in our vertex shader we
need to we need to handle these UVs
because we need to pass them into the
fragment shader so to do that what we
essentially want to do is okay let's see
yep so what we essentially want to do is
we want to call VSS dot u V equals UV
and then in frag we'll call vector to UV
here and then if we want to basically
set it equal we want to set it to a
texture well first of all we need that
sampler which we had from previous
episode but all we want to do really is
just that color equal to basically just
texture ok the texture we want and then
FSN UV and that is all we should do and
that will give us a thing now this UV
does text whatever we when we do arrays
attached it will have the actual texture
that we want to select and this will
probably be an actual array as well so
we'll set that up next episode but again
right now this is just how it's going to
work pretty simple and it's pretty much
open for working now so we set our
active texture being texture zero okay
when we have arrays we'll have one that
but the idea is when we do something
like texture zero we have two positive
on here I could have made this one for
example then I have two piles in one
here - the sampler okay that's how it
works so we'll just stick with zero
since that works and we're not using
we're neat one yeah
we're only using one so everything else
is the best but what we'll do is ah
that looks pretty good okay so really
all we have to do now is launch it and
it should work let me just make sure
that I'm doing all that could because I
am let's just see what happens I'm
reusing the test texture okay there we
go so yeah that works perfectly so if we
wanted to make sure that it works
perfectly I mean it does but first of
all let's add some lighting to it so
we'll just multiply by intensity that's
all we have to do okay I've got some
lighting with an alga right if I had a
head over here and make something that's
a bit better let's just draw a black
ball around here to make sure that we're
good and we'll maybe draw a white border
around the other part of it okay so okay
that lighting makes it difficult to see
but that is working which is great so if
I get rid of this real quick we know
that black and white okay great
so there we go and I might just make the
inside something a bit better like I
don't know that I'm looking for there we
go
alright so there we go that looks pretty
good to me
looks like our texture is working and
everything is the best so there we go
that's going to basically wrap up how we
can get our textures and stuff properly
into the actual shaders and whatnot we
are over the floor a bit but that's okay
everything else is looking pretty good
so next time we're going to talk about
having arrays of textures and everything
will work out okay so let me quickly
just explain is the reason we want to
raise the textures for example is
because I want to be able to be like I
want this sprite to be this texture and
I want this product here to be this
texture now unfortunately we've only got
one draw call so it's not like we can
set uniforms in between right we can't
do that because we're drawing this with
one draw call so it needs to be an
attribute and
needs to just be able to select from a
list of textures it's got in it and it's
in its video memory and be like I want
to apply this texture to this to these
two triangles I'll be a sprite so that
is how that's going to work get excited
to that it should be awesome I'll see
you guys next episode goodbye
you